here's Democrat activist Jake Tapper on
CNN and he's even acknowledging this
does not look good for old Joe he was
referring to the photograph of the Biden
garage I don't know what your garage
looks like but here's here's the
photograph so there's Biden and his
sweet 1967 Stingray but look on the back
left there I don't know if we can push
in there but that looks like a mess
that's worse than my garage that's worse
than my garage I mean that's not where I
don't know exactly where the documents
are in that garage but that does not
look like what a secure location would
be
yeah that does not look like a secure
location and it's also again once again
this is the key part even if it was a
secure location right he still was not
allowed to take the documents that's
just how this thing works so I will give
Jake Tapper credit Jake sometimes the
truth is so obvious even you get it
right that's a beautiful thing but here
watch this watch how CNN as a network is
trying to cover for by they have to
cover the story because it's breaking
everywhere even though they don't want
to cover it and it also because it also
makes CNN look ridiculous right because
CNN was pushing all the lies around the
laptop and everything else so the blaze
had an interesting retweet of a CNN
article so so I'll read the blazes
retweet of it first CNN uses image of
Biden receiving the medal of freedom
while trying to cover for Biden having
classified documents at multiple
locations right so look at the image
there that this is you're supposed to
look at this image on Twitter you kind
of just scroll past things oh and it's
Joe Biden there's Barack Obama and
everybody likes Barack Obama he's a
well-spoken dude and he's putting on a
blue ribbon on Joe Biden they must be
doing good things and then of course the
title actually says something White
House AIDS process to pack up Biden's
workspaces was muddled and hurried as he
used his office until the final minutes
of his vice presidency oh so they were
just in Rush guys you know what I mean
they had no idea what was happening they
didn't realize there was an election and
you know you've got like a month and a
half or what is it almost two months to
pack up but these guys were they were
just in a rush go classify documents
we'll get them over to Joe's Garage with
the Corvette I love that this whole
thing has become about a Corvette the
better story here would be if the
Corvette transformed and then like the
deceptive you know who got it all right
whatever
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]